ceausescus und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute sind wir auch
die sonne unter heute mache ich ein
video in dem ich fünf arten zu schwimmen
zeige die ihr nicht machen sollte
kürzlich gesagt ich bin mega außer atem
weil wir wie sau also 30 metern steht
mal zeigen und dem steg bis hierher das
sind 20 30 meter oder so und ich hatten
mit den dingen eine hand geschwommen so
und ich bin fast verrückt dabei ich
musste das ding abgeben nach der hälfte
so oder so wird das kein video sein was
ihr zu fall ernstzunehmen ist oder
irgendwie wichtige botschaft hat wenn
ich ehrlich bin einfach ein video dem
scheiß machen
okay und ich wollte es einfach dieser
fahrt raus machen weil diese aus nicht
so geil ist es aber noch nie im besten
video gehabt
also fangen wir an mit den fünf warten
über nicht stimmen sollte nummer eins
der hysterische
ich habe angst vor wasser weil ich was
ist so nass und so da war auch schon so
kleine fische drin da hast du gesehen
dass mit wasserspielen wo sie eigentlich
angst davor einzugehen aber das ist
gesehen ich schlage aber locker zehn
meter lang ich hatte glaube ich aus dem
paris eine rettung schon mal zwischen 10
ich bin stark inspekteur für algen an
der unterseite von badeplattform ich
also also wenn ich im wasser bin dann
möglichst wenig bewegen
einfach so so richtig ok ich kann nichts
schiefgehen hügel sicher dass wir nicht
wegen soll ganz sicher nicht wegen gar
nicht bewegen
verdammt keiner tag mega geiles wetter
sonne knallt wasser zu springen
ja ja da drin
checke meine musab galal tag und ich hab
die besten ruf so das war's von meinen
fünf arten die man nicht stimmen sollte
vielleicht habt ihr irgendeiner von
diesen arten schon mal in echt getroffen
in irgendeiner person erkennt ist und in
die kommentare schreiben besser mal
allererstes verwahrten video deswegen
hoffe ich dass es bei euch in gang
gekommen ist weil lassen darunter und
schreibt seit beginn kaum jahre und bis
zum nächsten mal